[Musik]
setzen sie mit frau merkel und in einem
vier-augen-gespräch zusammen würde
absolut nichts bringen absolut nicht
weil sie alle rechte in hand hat sie ist
die ober stiegen die wir sind alle
diesbezüglich gesteuert sie hat
narrenfreiheit absolut und die sich doch
überhaupt nicht
[Musik]
beim militär
frau merkel ist kein doktor sie ist gar
nicht sie ist nur von der stasi
ausgebildet wie man leute quält wie man
kinder entführt wie man leute tötet und
und angela merkel und kohl
was hatten die film verhältnis helmut
kohl ist ein jude oder jüdischen familie
hätte ich mir kennengelernt kinder
gemacht ein stefan ist die merkel wir in
allen reden weil frau merkel das ist ja
knüller mit welchen ländern befinden wir
uns den aktuell im kriegszustand mit 64
stück bitte mit 64 stück wie die
amerikaner alle gesammelt haben und wenn
ihr alle leute hier urlaub fahrt und so
weiter lange garantiert in einem land
das durch die amerikaner verführt mit
uns in einer fein staaten klausel stehen
die veranstalten 1000 steht nach wie vor
hoch das heißt also sie fahren in
feindesland um urlaub zu machen ich
fahre nach spanien sind im feindesland
ich fand sie können sie können auf
hannover ebenfalls lang 64 länder wo sie
hinfahren jetzt zu hause bleiben
arbeiten
[Musik]
die aldebaran vom sternbild aldebaran
die waren hier als diplomaten wer sind
die sogenannten alt areal der bueraner
sein sternbild und dann dürfen sie auch
wirklich mal mal im himmel gucken oder
in internet ist einfach ein anderer
stern und beobachten die erde seit
langen und die aldebaran haben also die
eigenen klasse schiff mit dem stärksten
und besten ausgebildeten führungs land
hier auf der erde immer zusammen tun
wollen
zufälligerweise mit adolf hitler damit
haben wir die flut schreiben gebaut und
sind auch mit den nach aldebaran
geflogen das ist sehr steil was mit auf
der flugschreiber an der außenhaut
angebracht war war auf alle warnten
zurückgekehrt keine steine fliegen sehen
da saßen jetzt alte traditionen und
interessant ist der blick wer hat uns in
dem zweiten weltkrieg weniger genutzt
die italiener oder die alte berater das
hat die italiener bis zu tun
die alte berater sind von einem anderen
planeten und die waren hier ganz normal
mit einem diplomatenpass aus spiele
irgendwie haben die ein herz eine lunge
die kürzlich mit den ganz normalen
kaffee treffen und zusammen schöne
städte kaffee und kuchen waren sie mit
einem alten barner schon mal auf der
erde kaffeetrinken dafür ständig
[Musik]
sie wissen ja dass ich mehrere eingänge
gibt zum mittelpunkt der erde und das
stadt mehrere völker gibt die dort leben
das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch
vision und unter anderem deswegen ja
auch der dalai lama von adolf hitler
gewesen dafür sehr viel investiert hatte
und partikel vom himalaya gehen
regelrechte gänge und treppen und da
wird weiß ich wohin ich war da auch noch
nicht wenn ich sie fragen darf was ist
so etwas wert außer dem ideellen wert
natürlich azizi was ich ihr leben wird
beantworten
ich bin doch kein fantast natürlich
[Musik]
erleichtert dass sogar sein würde damit
gebe ich zurück nach deutschland
[Musik]
[Applaus]